we do have some good news that came out
regardless of of what happens in this
presidential race or court battle i
guess it's a court battle at this point
the good news is that the the experts
were wrong about everything again the
experts told us that
trump's a racist right we won't condemn
white supremacy he's done it seven
million times but he won't condemn white
supremacy he's a racist he started his
campaign on racism
he called mexicans rapists and murderers
and whatever else
trump is doing better among hispanic
voters and black voters than any
republican in modern history and he's
doing better now than he was before
in 2016 even in 2016
donald trump got a lower share of the
white vote
than mitt romney had and white turnout
was stagnant it didn't grow from 2012
with romney to 2016 with trump
don't let anybody tell you trump is the
avatar of the
white nationalist white supremacist
romney did better among whites than
donald trump did
in 2016. and he got trump got a higher
percentage of black and hispanic voters
he got three percent more hispanic voter
african-american voters and he got two
percent more hispanic voters
which tilted some of those states
wisconsin ohio
florida pennsylvania tilted them toward
trump so according to the exit polls and
again take it with a grain of salt
but they're much better than the
prediction polls according to the exit
polls
president trump did better in 2020 with
every single race and sex
except for white guys it's it's like
perfectly backwards from what the
the establishment legacy apparatus has
told us
trump down five points with white
men which we're told as his exclusive
base no
he's down with white men he's up two
points with white women
but i thought the suburban women were
going to go against trump and doesn't
really look that way
up four points with black men that's
actually pretty significant
up four points with black women very
significant because there was some
evidence that trump was going to go
some who call i don't even know if you
can call it evidence now because the
polls are bunk
but there were some signs that president
trump was going to do better with black
men but he's going to do worth of black
women no he's up four points with both
of them according to exit polls
he's up three points with latino men
three points with latino women
up five points with other i don't know
who falls into other but he's up five
points
with them who knows maybe the polls will
be wrong
again i hope you enjoyed that short
segment from the michael knowles show be
sure to check out the full
episode linked in the description or
download the podcast
wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
[Music]
you